well let's gone to some spoilers now I
wouldn't have to cover this whole movie
we really know the whole film I mean
from the first half of spoilers the
things that really stood out to me in
terms of like spoiler worthy discussions
was the jcotton scene when it's American
Werewolf in London style I love that
touch I loved it like when I saw it
cause each other's characters kind of
annoying me at first yeah but I liked
how you know the spider buy because when
he gets bit by the spider like how Tom
Cruise's character it kind of brushes it
off like dude it's not even like a
poisonous spider bit and he starts to
turn into like a zombie and yeah there's
a clean like I like that I actually
enjoyed that sequence yeah I felt a
little B movie horde I mean I liked it
yeah well now when I was a horde touch I
wasn't expecting cuz it was legit pretty
creepy yeah and also I thought the movie
actually checked out on that character
yeah like that's a good thing about it
because I thought oh this is the end of
his character now this is like the left
cuz they kill off his kittens he dies
technically and conquer shoots him in
the plane crashes yeah so you assume
he's just dead so when he comes back he
comes back in the table eaters if you
got nose it was very good but I just in
case you haven't seen the movie in case
you decided to watch that a spoiler
warned I have a thing where he's kind of
like a ghost yeah time little Verity it
has the merest chooses what it was yeah
it was communicating to Nick and
explaining giving plot point the Nick
and stuff but their their interaction
back and forth I thought was really
funny
yeah really entertain and I believe them
as friends I did I thought you there
yeah you got this factor and this actor
together it was like now I believe you
guys is friends yeah and then that was a
nice thing to see you know yeah and the
thing is like that that's what's weird
about this movie to me because that arc
I think even though I think the writing
was clunky
it's kind of an all right thing they
built their like it's a moment that the
movie kind of builds something over time
pretty well and then forgets about it
for a really long time and then brings
it back
and that's a big problem the movie - is
it brings it introduces this cool
element to the film it's American
Werewolf in London style and then you're
gone like the rest of the movie they
like makes a cameo here yeah I do you
can't remember me yeah and like the
weird thing is for me I was like oh it's
nice to see you again like but yeah okay
so when they go into what they calls an
RTG a shield that's what I call it
exporter yeah you see Captain America
shield on the naval right okay so what
happens in the movie is the hell of an
spinning sequence that you see in the
trailer and like they were fighting in
the woods what saves the day is a bunch
of dude show up and they they capture
the mummy and or cool guns
yeah our poon guns and rather they show
up I just want shield this is ideal I
know it's shield and the Russell Crowe
seemed impossible moment you heard
diarrhea people well-equipped for the
head and I don't know I thought some of
the touch I like the little bit of
Universal and would have been fine for
me like when they're walking through the
lab there's a hand from The Creature
from the Black Lagoon there's a school
with vampire fangs ah haha
that was neat now on committal Don to
age right yeah yeah it's the whole point
of it of the conquerors issues him going
the whole movie one is like most of the
dialogue he is us yeah yeah so seeing
the lab was fine yeah one now once they
started going into like all the dr.
Jekyll and Hyde and then it annoyed me
when freakin nothing hotep what's her
name what's her name in this Nocturne on
memorable day I remember anomaly on the
Nama net you have an oven it's like tied
up and they're filling her with mercury
and you had a big problem with that
because it's not like she could have
been frozen a long time ago yeah he's
like this is really cold mercury we're
gonna pump it into her body she's gonna
freeze and we're gonna put her back
where she came from and like that that
sequence goes on for a while it seems
like it's been a long time she's not
that big
she's gotta be like bursting yeah with
mercury right now is pretty to care
about that like it just forgets about it
and she monologues and
up and she has time to like not feel
this horrible thing its curse it with
everything that's being explained
doesn't explain more yeah it's just a
lot of it's real explanation it shows
you your card and then like tells you
it's going to elect a laser it's slowing
down and they have this whole sequence
can you cut it and take place the
battery and they have this hope and they
have this whole sequence what starts to
happen is this is like stupid [ __ ]
source one of the mummies spider starts
crawling up a guy's neck and goes into
his cheek and then into its ear level
tiny time means nothing suspected slaps
it went to an exterior deep it is here
already like every human I know like if
your own hair products or solar long way
you're like oh my god you know and so
he's starting to get mummified and like
my same mummified eye means like
zombified yeah it is zombified and he's
32 centers spoil the plan so she could
break out of you know the being
objective of mercury and her chains but
then they have this whole other thing go
on that just seems so unnecessary and
strictly for universe building I just
annoyed this [ __ ] out of me I mean
better rapper than emails of BBS yeah I
mean they try to make it a boom what is
yeah situation it's when it's the whole
scene when Russell Crowe hides the [ __ ]
out I couldn't stand it I just couldn't
I'm like I like his performance with
Russell Crowe's doing like I like how he
how he made it a different guy and he
showed up but I like cuz he doesn't go
like full Hulk out like Oh still Russell
Crowe um you know just like a little
different makeup and [ __ ] and like CG I
mean don't even make it yeah but the
whole all them him fighting Hyde was
just so unnecessary I was just taken
away from the main [ __ ] they're like
should I be invested in the fact that
height is here or should I care that the
Mummy's about the bridge I attention him
my heart's attention has been really
divided a lot because it's not none of
it feels like heavy snakes yeah yeah
doesn't feel like oh man they got it
like stop the mummy from
breaking out with this thing with height
is happening this is kind of sort of
distracting plot point to me now well
that's that's what shoehorning and that
whole hide sequence partly messes up is
you really do get the sense that for
aamna it's just like she just has to
wait around until the circumstances were
yeah like that's how her whole plot him
yeah
and so yeah I don't know I
I mean mister hi like I I do appreciate
you showed up like I do yeah um I
thought it would make cooler food was
just doctor jackal yeah yeah but that up
for some time though I keep your little
hint at hide if you want him inject his
hand I don't care but don't do a whole -
I actually did it it isn't difficult I
did care about that because that was
like he's explaining stuff to Tom Cruise
that I feel like again it's another
thing the movie does the first time I'm
meeting you just because the audience
needs to know so like there's this whole
scene word where he almost holds out in
front of Tom Cruise and after like
administer a special medicine just like
in full view of this guy he's just met
who you know you don't know how he's
gonna respond and I don't know it's like
you never done this before
yeah you just hold out in front of
everybody and now I thought the last
paps are giving doctors nothing but to
go uh-huh yeah oh yeah that's the thing
is like hit run ups up for him to do the
Tom Cruise stick to start to run and dry
and I don't think that's because him
like a he's still you know he wanted
Harwich or nothing to do he was Karen
whiting gives none of these character as
much of anything to do in fact Courtney
just checks out the movie after yeah and
okay so by the by the ending once you
break down the ending a little bit um
okay so that thing from the beginning
that you're only shown to remind you
there is this like tomb underground and
she finally finding me with a night wait
which ending overtime yeah okay you mean
like oh yeah the ending where the tomb
is where the Knights are in the
beginning of the film
yeah they have the nice at the beginning
of the film and they're showing them
very something which that's where the
the which is usually the dagger was and
yes in it Easton is he had a 87 so the
tomb was super important yeah while
they're in the tomb he sofia boutella
killed the blonde chick in the movie
Jenny the character kills Jenny Jenny is
just dead Tom Cruise's upset all the
mummies and although of zombies
disappears just it's just on the on the
head underwater honkers and ominous
whole goal is to just [ __ ] slicing a
Tom Cruise like yeah your ritual do you
him with the fort would then set the god
of death yeah we're gonna hold another
rule stuff together that's all she has
been all she has to do but the whole
time she keeps urging him in it she
keeps punching him and then throwing him
around
yeah there doesn't ever seem like a
reason maybe hockey yeah yeah she gives
him every opportunity to do that thing
you know he's gotta do like she keeps
saying just giving and like what do you
give him for her to just do a hill to do
it you know what I thought of during
that scene I didn't explain everybody
I thought of Bruce Almighty I thought if
you can't force people who love you and
that's all I could think about in that
moment cuz [ __ ] yeah and like at that
point I didn't even buy her is evil and
you know I couldn't tell what was
happening with her anymore I was like
jealous
so Jenny like I think any while he was
going on I five others are trying to get
him to get over Jenny my best would seem
focused I'm like a pride thing yeah does
it look like cuz cuz because once you
imbue him with the god of death he's at
least got to be not a hundred percent
Nick still so like does it matter
yeah exactly I'm gonna fight why did you
kill him so and then Nick he kills
himself he comes back with Naaman heads
powers on what he sucks her and I
thought you know like give her life to
his girl and have some kind of
complicated scenario where like to keep
her life she's also got this you
spirit somewhere in her body but somehow
Tom Cruise realizes all the power you
have and just sucks the soul out of AMA
net yeah and I'm more more sitting there
going what's going on right now yeah
it's like this after the after a certain
point prodigy of the movie just takes
this sharp turn where it's like okay big
action scene and now we're serious and
now it's grim and when we're bringing
people back to the dead and then it gets
and then you have Jenny and Tom Cruise
scare circa week um yeah I knew that
could you try him over that he scares
her back to life yelled so loud and evil
voice with with you know what I assume
is this evil that lurks beneath that
we've been hearing so much out of him
and and yeah he does that sort of like
I'm gonna go tidy yeah that's when
audience numbers started laughing
because Jenny wakes up she's like Nick
you saved me because it's good whole
Nick's Ark is supposed to be he's not
supposed to be selfish and he's not
supposed to care about himself like
they're going to be sent that up so
obviously when she looks at him and goes
do you only care about yourself okay
right then and I was like oh so by in
his film he's going to learn to care
about her because this is going to be
great and Lego so he I don't I guess he
made a sacrifice he was already kind of
cursed and dead and so if I just go by
the plot you know it's like I understand
what they wanted to do and I understand
even the rate at which they did it if
I'm if I'm being friendly about it like
yeah at that point even after how wacky
certain things have been if he is imbued
with evil in order to save his love it
can never be either fine he's brooding
yeah at the end but uh nothing it
doesn't ever earned that choice it's
like the right and like the adventure
isn't solid enough to where the plot
alone can carry things and the
characters the actors are all good it's
the same thing like with Kong Skull
Island it's like the actors help the
material but the material doesn't give
you an insight as to who they are all
yeah so if the adventures not good
enough and
stakes don't have suspense and I don't
know much about these people it's it
goes the movies whole success and
failure goes on what I might be enjoying
at the time mm-hmm and that's the thing
about this movie that I'll say is
positive is like I had a really good
time watching it up until the end when
it's not a complete movie marian's but
it's surprising what a clever thing the
thing if you're trying to give it like
this romantic sort of ending that and
yeah so I'm trying to talk about this
whole time so I have a romantic type of
ending pretty like sacrifices himself
for her and like I don't I never wanted
to hurt you and they keep him in the
shadows and I don't feel like the film
never earned its romance I mean because
the movie has this little joke at the
beginning about how they slept together
today before and it's feelings for her
and stuff and I'm like wait I don't even
know how you two know each other what
you two talked about this movie made it
seem like that he just seduced you one
night so you could bang you on a one
night stand and steal your math is it
ever allude to you guys were talking for
a while crosses its wire because the
thing is their chemistry is is on-screen
appropriate it's weird like I feel like
all their chemistry comes from that moat
that Jack not from the story that led to
it so it's like they have appropriate
chemistry for for what that scene
implies yeah but yeah if you just look
at what you learned in the pub it feels
like a guy who just really wants to
prove it wasn't the one night yeah and
I'm not a shitty guy yeah okay I love
you I'm sacrificing my stomach right now
wait this really didn't earn any of that
I was like you can't just tell me that
he had feelings would never show me that
and then when they're wrapping up the
film they have mummy on the net she's
being consumed with mirtha bearing
arrogance and filling her up her so
coughing us up would ya you ripped her
out and then and then wrong crook it's
just X positioning those [ __ ] out of the
movie I could not believe the amount of
excellent like I think a regular
audience number would have been like
that's a lot of exposition right
yeah I just not only does it tell you
kind of what's going to happen next
maybe but it also tells you like what
just happened that you're aware yeah and
it is it kind of any questions that will
cover the expedition stuff in a second
but any questions is all story telling
of this moment yeah the phone has it's
like nice burying something at the
beginning we don't know what it was
unclear to me but it's the jewels yeah
yeah saying we don't know what at the
beginning of the film and then and then
you get up you know
okay here's going on Tom Cruise and and
he get prologue of the approach that I
thought a prologue of the mummy of who
come on it is and Russell Crowe he's
like narrating this I'm like who's he
talking to in this yeah I see the
narrator is really there yeah and it's
the thing is like to have him intrude so
I like again it any any one of these
scenes isolated might have worked but
yeah like the way the movie isn't like
why thanks universe is voicing the dark
universe for telling me because I was
like yeah yeah it's like it's clearly
stuff it's being told to the audience
and then they they try to mask the
expositional ending offer because
Russell Crowe is talking with Jenny
yeah and he's you know she's like you
know he sacrificed himself for me
yeah we all know we saw him he kind of
even a minute much said dad too and then
Joey let's look Chris I'm gonna watch it
with you he's just saying so much of
like he's a yes but he's a monster now
he's a different man he's gonna go on
adventures and he's gonna try to find a
cure but there's evil in him an evil
will follow it like whoa I like so much
time like there I'm sort of afraid of
what they're using the word monster for
now like if they're gonna change a
non-monetary
guy with a McCobb superpower that you
know occasionally has a brooding evil
you know
yeah I'm down ten times you would
little comic relief sidekick jQuery
answer Jake Johnson's brought back to
life thanks for bringing me back to life
thank you letter like I yeah yeah I
don't like that if it wants to do me in
and in all of way yeah and then Tom
Cruise like they said I so essentially
over here what the ending is saying is
Tom Cruise is the mummy yeah but that
not that's why no one ever memorized it
from the post yeah yeah I find no one's
ever talking about sofia boutella that's
why not even Alex Kurtzman talks about
her it's because it's it's it's setting
up that Tom Cruise he's the universal
monster now that's what this lets the
origin tale of Tom Cruise as the mommy
it's a cool switcheroo but I feel real
bad for her
it's a I mean it's a cool on paper but
yeah I am everything that's the best
little frustrating I think that's part
of why people in the reviews we've been
so upset about this is because like half
the ideas are all right yeah and it
squanders all of them in having not a
lot of salt on even the movie is not
focused well and when I said that ending
though when like the writing author
right in the desert and he has this
little sandstorm mine and I'm like this
was any of it true
I'm like wait a minute no me someone you
made the mummy super here if he was
going to follow it up like it I'm sure
he's having a great time with that hell
happened to your back exactly where's
your sense of adventure
yeah what is he Indiana Jones and why
are you trying to tell me he's gonna be
evil yeah yeah cuz you said him you set
up our origin tale not as a dark
character he is now super here you set
him up for when you're Avengers assembly
probably gonna be like Captain America
about the whole thing yeah cuz I have a
yeah he's probably the most noble of all
these yeah I got the military training
you know that you got bit by a mummy and
became a mother
yeah all right guys let's our spoiler
talk of the mummy you can subscribe to
dead
a become part of the reject nation click
that notification bell - on Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum house and go check out
our patreon for exclusive pert and
exclusive content